a report just released by the UN's
chemical weapons watchdog is blaming
Syria's government Air Force for sarin
and chlorine attacks perpetrated in 2017
let's go straight to diplomatic editor
James BAE's who's joining us live now
from the United Nations James tell us
more what this report has to say it
seems investigators have really come out
with some specifics here and it is very
much a first this is the report released
by the OPCW based in The Hague that's
the part of the international community
that looks at chemical weapons and
stopping the use of chemical weapons as
you know we've had chemical weapons
attacks taking place since 2013 many
people including the US government and
President Obama blamed the Syrian
government and President Assad for these
attacks but there's been no proof at any
stage that it was the Assad regime and
it's been a long drawn-out process to
try and get a proper investigation to
work out who was responsible for
chemical attacks this report which is
looking initially at three incidents is
very very clear the three incidents that
took place on the 24th of March 2017 the
25th of March 2017 and the 30th March
2017 as you say chlorine and serene
attacks they say they've looked at all
the possibilities and they say are the
based on a degree of certainty on
reasonable grounds they believe that the
Syrian government was responsible the
Syrian Air Force were flying the planes
they say they believe this would have
had orders from the highest level of the
Syrian government so this is something
very important this has been a long saga
on chemical weapons in Syria but for the
first time an international body not a
judicial finding but a technical finding
says the Syrian government did it James
those images that came out at the time
of these attacks there but they were
horrifying and you'll remember the OPCW
wasn't able to say who perpetrated these
attacks only that they occurred so this
new team is obviously able to
make that to be able to say who was
behind it that's quite major isn't it
this this new team that's able to do
these investigations and come out with
these reports yeah it's been a very very
long process and the OPCW was handcuffed
to begin with because of its own
procedures as you say they could say
that a chemical attack took place they
could say what some agent was used they
couldn't say who was responsible the UN
then decided to set up something they
called the joint investigation mission
the gym which was an OPCW UN joint
mission which was going to get to the
bottom of this well that gym started its
work it worked for a year it got renewed
for a year and then after many Western
diplomats will tell you you're close to
the point of apportioning blame the
Russians blocked the extension of that
gym so all its work stopped but
diplomats in The Hague where the OPCW
been based managed then to get a new
team set up of the OSI OPCW itself the
investigation on identification team it
has picked up the work whether stole the
gym stopped and it started its work this
is the first of the reports it's going
to carry out into incidents since 2017
and as I say three they've examined
initially and they believe the Syrian
government was responsible now the
problem with all of this is we now
basically have a verdict but will there
be any action against the Syrian
government the question of
accountability the question of of
justice for those in Syria raised its
head again and there I think we do have
a big problem because in the past the UN
Security Council has tried to refer the
case of Syria to the International
Criminal Court and guess what Russia has
a permanent member of the Security
Council and each time it's used its veto
to stop that thank for that James BAE's
there are diplomatic Edyta live from the
United Nations